tonight a lot of questions answered from
the clark county school district on the
return to the classroom thank you for
joining us
at five i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise
valdez school officials say they plan to
bring back
all students before the end of the
school year yes and there is a lot to
unpack tonight from sports returning
to how families feel about that
transition kristen drummond leads our
coverage tonight
with the all important dates kristin
well denise and brian superintendent dr
jesus jarrah did mention
all grade levels will be returning
before the end of the school year he
made that announcement
while visiting peterson elementary
school today we know that
pre-kindergarten to third grade students
will be going back on monday
but secondary school students can also
expect to be back in the classrooms
by next month here's a look at that
timeline
laura elementary grade students return
march 1st to start hybrid learning
then on march 15 all ccsd employees are
expected to be back in buildings
then on march 22nd grades 6 9 and 12
can return to in-person learning under
the hybrid model
the district wants grades 7 8 10 and 11
to start hybrid as well
on april six which is which is right
after spring break
also on april 6th pre-k through grade
five will likely return to
five days a week in person learning and
not be hybrid learning anymore
are welcome to stay engaged with us as
we bring our kids back because
our kids are going to need this entire
community
to art to wrap their arms around them to
get them to succeed
academically just as they're going to
succeed athletically
and just as they're going to succeed in
their performing arts
activities like theater band drill teams
are expected
to return as well there will not be an
additional survey sent out to secondary
school families regarding
what they prefer the school district
plans to look at data
from the last one reporting live in las
vegas kristin drummond
8 news now all right kristen thank you
so as to